Oh what's up hey guys what's going on
it's very early
it's a [ __ ] early comedy time in
comedy time it's 10:30 in the morning
and we are live in Phoenix I slept like
3 hours how long did you sleep about
three about three hours court what about
you all right in there yeah
everybody okay good so is anyone did any
of you wake up and do three lines of
cocaine this morning to alert yourself
close I drank a monster all right that's
like seven lines everybody I ever see
drinking monsters like wearing board
shorts and they have a really weird hat
on it's just like no you know he just
beat his girl it's like the ed hardy of
beverages this podcast is brought to you
today by Monster Energy
[Laughter]
don't break stereotypes that's what
she's very I like that I like that
typical monster she doesn't conform she
doesn't drink coffee but she had four
monsters guys let me introduce my guest
first of all this is Dave fails we are
at the all things comedy fest in Arizona
we're in Phoenix yeah I feel weird like
I'm staring into the camera it's weird
that the cameras there and you guys are
over here why are you staring into the
camera
I don't know because in case there's
like murders probably at least five
people watching this right now this is
life I'm gonna go I'm gonna go four and
a dude on monster so guys we're at the
all things comedy fest this is so fun
this festival this is the first festival
all things comedy has put together it's
at like two clubs here and a theatre and
we got a podcast studio so if you're in
Phoenix you should come by and check it
out there's like shows all day go to all
things comedy calm and let me introduce
my guests I'm so happy first of all I've
been wanting to have this [ __ ] right
here on for so long like how long have
we been trying you know I live in LA so
now it's hard to get you yeah you're a
hard woman to get I'm hard to get I I'm
get about guys who just drive to Phoenix
and she's be on the show
it's a long drive darien and my car is a
bike i saw you on a bike the other day
shot online and I was gonna honk but I
thought that would have been creepy
please dude no one does since I turned
thirty shut but I Drive a Prius so
wouldn't have been like a manly huh
green no would have been a honking she
would have been like how has no one
invented some kind of device that honks
your car with like different phrases
yeah like how is that not a thing I
always thought of that too right like
you hit a button number one and and it's
like a polite like please move forward a
little or the light turn green and then
like number two is like what up [ __ ] or
right thank you sir mine would be like
move that [ __ ] Korean minivan get the
[ __ ] out of the way oh wait what was the
name of your podcast again court in
sensitivity training that mean
sensitivity training I also have Joel
Kimmel and Brian Richie which you guys
both have a show coming out on Comedy
Central you guys are both part of Kevin
Hart heart of the city yeah we are it
sounds so moving a heart of the city
like you guys are gonna tell sad
nostalgic stole no it's actually Kevin
Hart he goes around two cities in the
country that have big comedy scenes and
he just like a showcase of like 16 to 20
comics then he'll pick like four that he
likes and he cast you on an episode so
Brian and I along with J Mack and
Terrance d'Alene were cast on the
phoenix episode and it premieres
November 3rd on Comedy Central
oh I'm so excited for the record so
short I was the only girl and it was
Brian J Mack Terrance and Kevin and I
was the tallest one all right let's get
right to it so first of all I'm so
grateful that you guys got up for this I
was supposed to do this yesterday I like
posted everywhere I was gonna have
people coming and then and then my
flight got just cancelled I woke up and
there was no flight for me which was
kind of goods I was hungover so I got to
sleep extra hours but now these guys
they're troopers they got up at 10
o'clock in the morning to talk about
dating and sex you're are you single Joe
no you're not single boy friend oh my
god dude Jill is like me she was married
for how long were you married for
yesterday would have been our 21 wedding
21 year wedding anniversary how long
have you been divorced
a year and a half that's it yeah and
you've had two boyfriends already I
haven't had one bye honey why this guy
that I dated
we were not boyfriend/girlfriend he made
that very clear in text she sent me when
he told me to remove all pictures of him
from my social media why they were not
boyfriend-girlfriend and all references
to me being your man that was not
something we just someone else that was
jealous of me and I had to take my
pictures down of him so you know that
that day was throwback Thursday and I
posted his ass you girls whatever you
guys break up with a guy and you like
you've been with a guy and you posted
all these dumb photos on social media if
you guys being together at all these
shitty events do you ever like go back
and delete them so that you don't have
the memory of him on your social media
good question I have done that if the
guy is like if the guy was such a piece
of [ __ ] that looking at the photo makes
me want to murder people I take the
photo but even but I mean I mean you
need I'm sure you've been in
relationships where there wasn't that
awful but I mean do you still go back
and take down the photo of the well see
I was with my ex-husband from before
they had the internet so we didn't have
that problem so we got divorced a year
and a half ago and then like you know
five or six months later I went out with
a guy for like two months and I mean we
were fine we broke up like friendly and
nice and I thought it was fine and I
wouldn't have taken those pictures down
cuz it wasn't like we got a fight or he
was a jerk it was just we you know he
wasn't that into me yeah so yeah I
thought it was fine until he messaged me
a few months later like I have a new
girlfriend and she's pretty jealous and
I really care about this relationship
you know what I would do that message if
he was like you have to take down the
photos I'd be like send me five hundred
dollars I just posted a picture of him
on throwback Thursday I was like I
cropped him out just enough so you could
still tell it was him so when she was
stalking my Instagram which clearly she
was doing she could still see it I'm
like you know what that's right I get it
I've been the jealous girl I have
definitely had been but you know let me
make that just like you know what
unfollow me I could see her saying block
her I don't want you having your
pictures but you cannot contact me and
be like please remove order these people
well not that old he wasn't quite hot 20
he's just certain 29 last year
wow you really date old dudes yeah wait
so I mean this is the thing I'm kind of
like the girl version of a fuck-boy in
the sense that I don't post well I'm not
but I don't post photos of guys I'm
dating on my social media because like
one I'm almost never exclusively dating
someone so I don't know not by my choice
by their choice they never want that but
also because then when it ends then it's
like you have to you know go through the
whole like do I keep these up and that
everyone asks you what happened and
people visit because I never think it's
gonna end like if I'm posting a boxer
with you it's because I'm like I'm in it
you know what I mean yeah like I'm
always such a nice I am no one's dating
someone that I was like maybe not the
minute I start dating him I know it's
soon to be over real the minute the
minute we're together I'm like this
won't wow what do we have sex I go it's
only a matter of time hey [ __ ] you and
leave you they always [ __ ] you and leave
you those guys dude I can't I've never
dated one of those guys I don't know I
mean what about you I don't think
anything will last any more am I just
jaded I assume everything will end in a
year that sucks that's a terrible
feeling to have but I think it's just
cuz you haven't met somebody who've made
you feel differently yeah you know I
mean because like you're a catch
definitely I mean obviously you're very
lovely and attractive by tonight you
know you are kids you've got a lot going
for you you're ambitious you're out
there that is intimidating to guys I
mean I am a catch like inside on the
outside not that much no I for sure but
that's it's still intimidating guys you
know you have to be a strong man to be
with a strong woman you really do and
guys are kind of like I'm not sure I
just want I just want one that will
definitely take care of me
I'm done with being oh I gotta be in
charge yeah I pay when we go out I'm
like if you reach for your wallet I'm in
love go for the wallet [ __ ] I went out
with a girl I went out with a girl about
a month ago and she was very young it's
chic she I don't approach young girls
young girls have recently been
approaching me more than than in my past
and so until this girl we went to we
went to dinner and I went to pay for
dinner and she goes no no I got this and
I was like no I got this dinner she goes
well I have the next one and I was like
alright we're having a second date yeah
we're going for Lobster and we're going
that's funny I only reach for my wallet
when it's coffee that's the only time
that you're cheap or whatever it's that
you know you're a single person on a
budget and you're living and you're
trying to me so you're probably not just
like I'm gonna spend a hundred dollars
on dinner yeah I mean if well and also I
think whoever asks you like whoever does
the asking out should pay in my opinion
right once it gets past like where you
pull out a few times that and then I'll
like go back and forth but at the
beginning if they're the one being like
can I take you to dinner I'm not gonna
pay there's nothing creepier than
someone like getting weird about money I
would rather pay for a hundred strangers
that I've never met for alcohol that I
didn't drink then have one person
questioned me over a dollar like that
yes I will break up with you immediately
if I see that you're a cheap tipper or
you do this weird like are the sides
extra I'm out extra I had someone say
that yeah like one guy I wasn't dating
him but he was like part of a little
group worth and I was like yeah I could
know how do you feel about that if
you're doing price check that's a bad
yeah
have you ever had someone used like a
coupon like I had a guy pull out a
coupon on a date you got a do on the
you gotta like you got to conspire with
the waiter right right was a waiter for
a long time have you ever had anyone
conspire with you and uh yeah and I
would help him out you know what I mean
obviously it's in my best interest
genuinely want to help right you don't
know me but but I'm like you know I got
I kind of got him what do they do like
pull you aside and go like hey man I'm
on a date but I'm on a budget you think
you could like know what it wasn't as
much a coupon it was like I don't know
if these cards are gonna go through oh
yeah can you just run on the side of it
don't work out let me just give you
another one let me just figure out this
battement you know what I mean like
trying to work out paper I don't know
why you were gonna date with a with a
suspect
I can't I think sometimes you don't
thinking it's gonna be fine then you
realize like okay this sodas were each
three dollars like you start adding it
up in your head you're like oh my god I
might have the server comes like do you
want dessert and the girl starts
thinking and the guys like how do I get
out how do I run away from this right
now I had a guy ask me diarrhea I'm
doing I'm feeling a touch gassy from
here no I wanted to take you somewhere
special for dessert I had a guy asked me
if we could leave and go somewhere else
after he looked at the menu because it
was too expensive like and then he took
me to McDonald I swear to God took me to
McDonald's and then and then he ordered
a half coke half Diet Coke I broke up
with you six times by now I know court I
feel like I'm curious about you because
you're because okay cuz course hot like
super hot very handsome right and all my
girlfriend's think that like one night
which girlfriend you're not fat you look
fantastic
well I've lost a lot of weight yes you
look amazing I don't Joe like eight nine
years yeah our first show it stand up
live with Bobby Lee was with you
yeah when it first opened yeah and I and
we saw each other backstage last night
and I just want to pay you a compliment
because you you look amazing and but I
was saying to her last night like I
never thought of you is like fat a photo
last night of her
and I was like a photo was more Ralphie
May and I was almost bigger than him I
know but I mean but I mean you were
definitely you definitely weren't as
thin as you are now but you weren't but
you were I never thought of you as like
being like someone like you didn't want
to leave your fries in the green waste I
used to have a roommate years and years
ago I lived in Santa Fe New Mexico for a
year and I had this roommate that was
this costume designer she was a big
woman I love her to pieces she's a
sweetheart she was a big woman and I
would go to the store and I would buy
stuff and she was only in town like a
month of the year but I had to hide the
food oh my god she would come in town
and like she would gnaw a hole bag of
Cheetos my jam right there
and I'd come in and I'd be like hey
cheese fingers I just bought these
Cheetos I'm not gonna lie I'm a bender
like I'm a healthy eater and I don't eat
a lot but when I do I totally been
jealous yeah yeah I do I'll eat a whole
plate of chicken not last night I ate a
whole plate of chicken nachos manatee
poppers he stood over those poppers he's
standing there last time in case you
don't know boys he's the [ __ ] best
man mercy and mercy was like and she got
this huge like it's a pizza box full of
nachos and she's standing as she's kind
of just nibbling at these nachos and
Paul goes Paul goes I'm just I'm just
kind of in your eating I go no dude
you're not lightly eating you're diggin
in [ __ ]
he was like standing over him and it's
like you know when someone takes another
bite before they finished chewing that
that's not grazie
that's [ __ ] and he was like standing
and he was like not moving away and it
wasn't and it wasn't like he was never
like licking his fingers because he was
going back in his stand-up life does not
play around with the food and their
nachos there are one of those things
maybe they're huge and they're really
good and so I do not fault virzi for
that that is
I only faulted him for saying that he
was just having a bite just having one
no you're not
none of the comments must realize that
the badge for the festival gets them
free food over there because when they
handed me this badge he said this is
good for food and drinks at copper blues
so I got the nachos for free and then
all the comics that came up here start
eating them we're like I should give you
money
I'll take $10 I made $100 to go for the
free food because we usually get paid
terrible but luckily the clubs in
Arizona treat you really well I think
their reason so many comics are such
heavy drinkers it's just because we're
so used to being so broke that when the
alcohol is free hat we feel like we have
to take it no matter what let's get back
to your friends I want to sleep so like
you're very you are high you're single
like do you want okay I feel like hot
guys in LA especially when they get to
your age where they're still single they
don't look right no kids yeah oh my god
you're like dream man that's what I'm
saying at this point are you like I'm
never committing because I can play the
field forever here no I want to get
married I'm a licensed minister I will
marry
honestly I want to get married that is
the best thing I've ever seen it's like
even like a five dollar ring for my I
think I dropped this one with the green
ones wants to get married you're single
you're what like 44 or something 53 oh
wow he looks like he's 40 and he's so
hot anyway healthy like he doesn't drink
and he meditates he's like perfect guy
sober he plays golf he has a nice house
I did the podcast your god wants to
marry him now I should just have you
walking in front of me not a bad view
don't get cuz you really are a great
catch though if you want a relationship
and you can't find someone then I feel
like we're all fun I'm not
got a man it's not as easy and it's like
and it's also you know I'm a comic so
I'm not I'm not I'm not like home all
the time been more perfect
I'm not damn I'm actually I'm actually a
really good like I'm very easy to hang
out with I just don't I just don't like
like I don't like bars and clubs yeah I
I hate bars and clubs I can't stand it
what do you I love to go out to dinner
and do stuff yeah so it's like if you
want to go out to dinner and or you want
to go like I'll go to the museum I'll go
to movies I'll go concerts I'll go do
all those things that you want to do but
I will not go to you know EP and LP or
one of these [ __ ] nightclubs that
it's like it's like a lounge E bar
rooftop bar it is it's a nightclub
I've only been anywhere anywhere there's
a line out the door they're like [ __ ]
ubers line up walk the street that's not
wrong I've only been there for like
sunset on the rooftop it is nice but
maybe it must change over into a
nightclub I've never I all I know is is
that that's just like not my scene so I
don't like that scene so we're taking
applications for wives for Court yeah
hold on before anyone else applies tell
me more yeah for real
if you weren't a comic I mean that's the
thing it's like I try to stay away from
comics although I'm not very successful
at it you're not fair to me though like
this is the problem so like I recently
sort of sort of dated a comic kind of
but the problem is like I'm not telling
I would never tell him I'll never tell
you never tell me I didn't even know he
was really comic cuz like oh then he's a
shitty comic if you didn't know he's a
comic right it's actually pretty
successful really no it doesn't matter
the point is Jill doesn't the point
it doesn't mean bad mouthing the point
is I went out with him for like 30
seconds and then I remembered why I made
this no Comics rule because even if it's
going well here's what happens as a girl
and every girl listening one
understand this like let's say I want to
go to the Comedy Store one night just to
see a couple friends and I'm not going
up but he's going up now if I show up it
looks like I'm coming there because he's
there and not just cuz I'm a comic
hanging out so I start to psychoanalyze
everywhere I would go too old for too
old to not today miss he's too old to be
like where he is in terms of how he
thinks of relationships because that's
what I was getting out with you most
guys that I meet in LA do not want
girlfriends they just don't they might
date you but they don't want a
relationship so you're so rare looking
for one but I would ask you like did you
say though later in life you know more
what you want and what you look
absolutely I think the difference is the
work is when you like the first thing
that you have to overcome is a guy if
you ever want to be successful dating
anybody is jealousy yeah like that's the
biggest because the minute because once
like I don't get jealous anymore you
don't at all doesn't I never get jealous
it's like if you want to do if you want
to if that's still you know if that's
where you want to go or if you want to
do that fine but it's like but I it's
like also I draw a line it's like if
that's your behavior that's not
acceptable behavior to me
yeah I don't like when girls try to make
guys jealous yeah games games to me is
get the [ __ ] out you're supposed to care
about what is going to feel it's not
even hurting it's like here's a great
example like it like like I hate texting
like cuz I'm just have the III I'm I do
you call yeah so I don't I don't mind
texting I don't mind I don't mind if you
text someone I don't mind I don't mind
texting obviously if there's like you
know if you just want to say hey okay so
see you it you know blah blah blah we're
doing this but but if we're gonna like
you know I don't if I text you and you
don't text me back for two hours and
it's like and you're just kind of
waiting cuz you just don't want to text
because you want to wait you know it's
like then they text me back
and it's like I just delete it and just
go you know what [ __ ] off that work you
know what's better this is what my kids
do you have an iPhone I do you leave
people on read receipts so that they see
that you read it and they know you read
it but you just don't write back that's
what my kids do it's like a little like
that's why I don't have an iPhone by the
way just but really you know I know I
would kill myself maybe with the book
bubble when you're like trying to think
and like deleting it out wow that's
actually interesting that's why I don't
have an iPhone because I don't want to
know who's leaving me on read because
I'm crazy and I get like obsessive but I
have my I have an iPhone and I just have
my where you can't tell if I read yeah
mine's like - yeah because I don't cuz I
just it's just I have people in my life
that it's like man especially my mom is
because of my mom texts now and it's
like I love my mom to pieces but it's
like she texts me stuff and it's like no
I'm not able to yeah be like oh shoot I
just got this or whatever and sometimes
you just need that little just saw your
tag yeah sorry
well my phone was dead and I was like
[ __ ] why did I [ __ ] yeah I just like
when my thing with the texting is that I
feel it causes so many problems that
could be alleviated in like a two minute
foam roll cuz if you're going back and
forth and back and forth trying to even
like making plans it's so much easier to
just talk on the phone
well yeah people who won't talk on the
phone well not only that it's like the
worst thing about texting is you can
never tell the tone of a conversation
well I'm a very sarcastic cynical you
know I have a cynical and sarcastic you
know tone to what and it's like and I I
hate to have to type haha right after I
say something like like anal you know
but it's like but then I hate to have to
type type haha just to see their
response girls get so hyper analytical
like I dated a guy who would send so
many emojis like he would always emoji
all his text and so then when he
wouldn't send an emoji I would always
think something was wrong or he was not
flirting right and then I'm like
starting to get to a point where there
was one point where it's like he really
pulled back on the emoji
I started to get your purses he not like
you don't send me emoji Mikey stop
sending emojis that point that society
has come to that's really funny
alright so wait have you ever been
married no have you been married
I have not and also doesn't have kids
and also would love to be a dad I mean
you would be a great yeah you want to be
a dad pregnant I'll sell you the baby
alright yeah why do you have to sell it
I never said that before on stage you
just kill it well you know what right
now we're still allowed to I might get
pregnant just so I can have an abortion
cuz its legal right now I'm just saying
just kidding I'm probably too old for
that over as well as my David Blaine
rape joke on Twitter oh you know people
went crazy on you it's jokes people
relax more pregnant there was a comedian
this is actually did you hear about this
a little bit you started to last night
there I got it you got into your nachos
oh yeah yeah there was a comedian that
got so pissed at me about this David
Blaine joke which by the way I don't
think that you should rape people and
David he's a magician right he's well he
probably I mean he probably at least
hypnotized her into [ __ ] him he's not
a magician but let's be honest they're
all they're all they're all [ __ ]
wait do you think that there's real
magicians they can do actual no the only
got the only time I've ever seen
anything the only time I've ever seen
anything that I consider to be real
magic is if you've ever a girl squirt
yeah no I can I can make that happen
cut to commercial right okay but no the
but what it is is I've been to the the
Magic Castle in Los Angeles and the
Magic Castle if you ever get a chance to
go go
you gotta get invited right yeah yeah
there's somebody somebody who's a member
what but it's not it's not that
difficult it's it's it's easy to get
into but you just know someone and
they'll take you but they have this
thing that's called close-up magic and
you go down in this room and there's
little bitty tiny tables and you sit
down with guys that do these card there
it's called close-up magic because
you're sitting right there with them
right and they do these card tricks and
they do these things now to me that is
like that is the most ultimate thing
because he had this this guy did this
one thing where he basically would have
someone pick a card and then he and he
did he went through this whole thing and
and I know there's some but and the guy
person signed the card you know with a
sharpie and they did this thing on it so
they made it weird so it was a weird
signature it's not something I love that
there's no way that he could have
there's no way he could now however that
however he did that I don't know but
eventually he ended up having an
envelope that was folded up that he
pulled out yesterday he however it
happened and he pulled it was just this
most elaborate thing to me that was
magic nothing and then we went to like
the big room and this guy did this magic
with birds but at one point I saw his
coat open and I saw all the birds tucked
in as his coat [ __ ] so [ __ ]
[ __ ] I can tell you got the birds
because because they train birds these
guys you know that do burden they when
you see these programs really magicians
their bird well know what they do is
these guys all have birds in the
magician's that use birds they've
trained these birds they're trained and
they sit inside pockets of their coats
and they sleep and they they've trained
these birds to do this so they will
literally lay in a person's coat and
sleep until they pull them out and they
place them in something and then they
will fly but it is but I I asked because
I talked to a guy who was he goes oh
that's all those her trained birds so
they trained these birds so that kind of
[ __ ] to me and the illusion stuff I know
a girl in Vegas
who used to work in my show in in at the
Palms who was a magician's assistant and
it's all and it's definitely a skill
we're not it's not it's you're no you're
not it's not magic right the card stuff
the close-up that's my card stop is like
it's beyond a skill
it's yeah our friend Bob Komodo does
that and he says oh it's the greatest
thing to ever see because there's no way
to figure it out yeah when it's so good
that it makes you mad yeah you're like
that's impossible
like I remember I used to pennant I used
to go to Penn & Teller show a lot and in
Vegas because Penn Jillette used to come
to our shows and I knew his wife really
well and so we used to go to the shows
all the time and I've heard friend
antennae go let's just go to Penn &
Teller and he'd get us great seats and
we go in and they used to do this thing
where they would pass around an envelope
during the show and and everybody in the
audience would sign or do something and
at the end of the show they would do
this big and it was just like how in the
[ __ ] that that to me was like that's
magic I love it I love it because there
it's so intricate how it's done it's
such in a problem I'm sure at some level
it's the simplest thing that you just
can't you don't know but at the same
time it's like that's the coolest thing
I know how did David Blaine raped you
what happened
no David Blaine did not rape me just for
the record I think kourt's yeah oh my
god you would be like this magician like
cool chick Burt would marry me if I knew
magic there a bird shop in Phoenix that
we can get into it's good dude that
would be amazing
all right you're sweet though what it
was it because people got Maddie yeah I
think I talked about a little on here I
just said it so David Blaine this girl
said David Blaine raped her and but then
you know she said that and by the way he
might have because right we don't know
we weren't that wasn't there right but
she said she felt very stoned and very
relaxed and woke up naked and I said
that sounds like a magical evening oh
she said she's stoned relaxed and naked
but super hashtag at me too
no I did not have a hashtag to me passed
up me too with the question mark watch
your hashtag hashtag me to everything's
okay I know I
fortunate that we've come to that point
where you can't even make it I mean I
know some jokes are in bad taste but I
did read that joke when you made it and
I thought it was funny and a lot of guys
liked it and then a lot of girls liked
it but then this one comic got so mad at
me she got so mad oh it was a girl it
was a female cause I got mad at me and
she started talking I know I'm not gonna
say but uh but here's the thing that she
got mad at me and then the next night I
was doing a show and she she was there
not on there she was hanging out and she
came up to me and started being like so
nice to me like you look amazing what
have you doing to work out what's going
and I was like I don't know what to say
I don't know what to say in those
instances we EB do you call them out and
do you just go like weird because last
night on Twitter you raked me over the
coals no I was like you know I don't
know why I look so good lately I've been
watching a lot of David Blaine because
that's a situation where awkward I would
literally go I would literally have to
say to someone like I have this this
kind of Creed in my life where it's like
I don't want to be in uncomfortable
situations yeah so I will I will go up
to someone in that sit in that situation
I'm gonna go up and say hey listen I'm
sorry if I did something to offend you
but I feel really kind of weird that you
tweeted that back if you have a problem
message me you know just like let's just
tell me what the deal is because I want
to clear the air yeah and you I feel
like if you do that in your life like
you'll never have an uncomfortable
situation is falling in love with Kourt
McGowan today no no but I think Court
should be the next Bachelor for real
wouldn't he be a perfect fact he's so
wood we were like transcendental
meditation together and all of that I
don't know I don't have enough money to
be sure you have more than most
out-of-work actors they have none of the
bachelorettes have money like who cares
neither to the batch I knew one of the
bachelors she was a piece of [ __ ] and I
had no money and he was just one three
girls when he went on to just say this
that that that show is such a crock of
[ __ ] right I totally agree no no no
we're out with him it's my date night
tonight well what nowhere in the world
twenty-five smokin hot girls follow
one-half of Fagor rip currents really I
do not fall in love and get married and
then they all are like sobbing when they
get kicked off like you've been there
three days how are you in love it's
ridiculous although I may be they all
have do you think they all hook up do
you think they all have sex
you wouldn't I think I think a lot of
them do I think that's why they all cry
when they yeah right catch the feelings
yeah what's going on
do you want kids I'm not like I'm not
opposed to it but I'm also not like gosh
I need to have kids cuz I don't want to
be I'm 53 I don't want to be like 74
with in a wheelchair with an oxygen tank
rolling a ball back to my kids stand
downhill his grandpa's gonna roll the
ball back to you but I like I used to
like when I was really young like I was
like 23 I lived with a girl who was 25
who had two kids and I would loved those
kids to pieces you know now they're like
now they're 30 I could probably do it
that's a good position you're like you'd
go either way like kids you you wouldn't
eliminate a woman if she wanted them and
if she didn't you would still either one
I mean it's yeah but at the same time
though I have a hard time I have a hard
time believing that bringing up a child
in today's society from now I'm not
saying if you have a 13 year old or 14
year old but I'm saying you know having
a newborn kid today in today's world is
pretty [ __ ] scary because there's
it's not like like I went to public
school I went to you know yeah I went to
college and it wasn't $75,000 you know
you didn't have to sell your house to
put a kid through school there's a there
was it was a different time and I'm not
like this isn't like you know in the all
in the old days this was not that long
you know and now things have gotten to
the point where it's if you have a child
now you better have about $350,000 to
get them through high school that's so
scary I don't have children and like $11
[Laughter]
to eat out of trash can freak you out a
little bit today to think about like if
you have a kid that wants to go to
college you know like I have a my
younger brother I haven't I have a
nephew I have two nieces who are one
needs to graduate at college one niece
believe it or not who's still who's also
know she's graduate no she's in college
and then I have two nephews and one of
my nephew's is like honest you know is
senior in high school and he's going
he's applying to colleges now and it's
like how the [ __ ] you gonna pay for this
I'm very I'm very my I have a college
fund for my family for my kids otherwise
I'd be like you better get those grades
up not get your grades up you better you
better scholarships he's better be what
you better be like Asians oh no I know
what my kids are my kids are that smart
they're just my son like if he applied
himself one ounce he would be like the
guy but he's like straight A's and like
a B well and he's always like man I'll
do my home tomorrow like never bother
but I'm like I went for I got a
scholarship for the first two years and
then I paid for the second I took out
loans for a second to think but it
wasn't that bad I ended up I think I
would like 30 grand when I graduate but
but that's okay but now now for example
you you have a kid that you don't want
to send a public fourth grade fifth
grade sixth grade it's 25,000 a year to
send a kid do not not even that not even
the best one shitty way I hear that a
lot a lot of people I know in LA send
their kids to private schools they live
in great neighborhoods they're like yeah
but the schools here are terrible but in
Arizona like most people go to public
school like then everything's safe I
mean obviously you know yeah well I live
in Kilburn Jerry
I think people are just too careful with
their kids that's yeah I think Rome
right in the fire dude when I was a kid
I would leave the house on my bike I was
like eight I would leave the house on my
bike and come back like six hours later
dirt all over me and my mom be like
where'd you go I feel like I was
climbing dirt hills all day and like no
one was but that's a different but
that's what I mean like it's not like
that now I mean you got it you got a kid
that rides her bike to school you better
have a tracer on him and a drone for me
no one has tried to rape me in a van and
I'm a little offended I feel like every
kid should get a GPS system and every
boy should get a vasectomy and then when
they get married you get the vasectomy
reversed and then you're at 18 you're
allowed to turn off your GPS tracking
device - that would be great let's talk
about your parents can track you when
you're a child and once you're 18 you
can have that turned off and I wouldn't
turn it off I want people to know where
I am again see like that's that's [ __ ]
up I know it sucks you have to but
wouldn't it be great I know but it's
like I remember when we were I remember
like I grew up in the seventies and but
I mean I grew up when literally you your
parents like you came home from school
and your parents were like get the [ __ ]
out of the house and you were you were
out of the house and you came back
whenever dinner was right when I
whenever my mom made some shitty meal
meets it all have to come back and eat
her shitty food I loved my mom she could
not cook and my mom used to make lasagna
with cottage cheese was the worst food
ever cottage cheese is just so gross
when she was like it was like ricotta
cottage looks similar it's fine but I
think I think today like like today you
can't you have to like you know kids
it's just not
there's too much weird [ __ ] out there
and you can't do that and then if but
then if you're tracking your kid then
it's like there's no freedom as I don't
track my kid like to know what he's I
just mean like in case someone steals it
was that enough
about kids can we talk about vasectomy
over cutting because I want guys to
start getting more vasectomies I am
pissed off that guys don't get more I
know guys that never want kids and
refuse to get a vasectomy cuz they're
like scared to have their you know dick
invaded or whatever they're afraid of I
don't the little surgery its minor i I
just I mean I don't think it's a big
deal but I just it's like I'm not sure
where I'm at so that's why I don't know
if you don't know it's okay but if
you're like definitely I don't want kids
yeah yeah a lot of guys are like why
aren't you on the pill and I'm like you
never want kids why don't you get a
vasectomy yeah why do I have to put
hormones in my body every day why would
you ever risk it if you really didn't
want kids I'd be like going in and
getting that taken care of me too it's
really pulling out so it really my
daughter Allison just saying why was she
a pull out baby she was a surprise never
gotten a girl pregnant so you know
probably shooting plain yeah I'm barren
also because like I mean I will tell you
what I win this podcast finish let's go
do it
yeah I will shoot a huge load in you and
we'll see if anything happens I feel
fertile I've never had a guy on the
podcast I've hooked up with before and
I've always wanted to and he's like
let's [ __ ] right now all right I got to
read this last connection so I have this
listener who sent me a question actually
think it's a really funny one I think
this girl's name is weed ja I'm not sure
how to pronounce it but okay here's a
question she goes this is so funny I
started dating a guy a couple weeks ago
and he just adopted a cat I'm super
allergic to the cat even taking medicine
doesn't work every time we hang out at
his place I feel bad I don't want to
tell him to give away his cat but I
really like him and don't know what to
do and I'm like oh this is an
interesting one because I first of all
you're dating a dude with it already
you're you're [ __ ] one strike again
did a cat oh of course that's the best
way if you're gonna get a pet you have
to adopt it yeah
but still but not a cat you can't find
one in a dumpster because that's like
I'll get a cat that's like I want a pet
that loves that that that I can love
that won't love me back that shits in my
house that's that smell makes my house
smell like [ __ ] it's just there's so
many wrong things with so not a cat
person to the point of there's this I
talked about this guy on my podcast
there's this rock star that I'm like the
hugest fan of like crazy it's weird al'
its weird out it's weird out I always
wanted to [ __ ] Weird Al so one day this
guy dm's me and I like out of the blue
he deems me and I almost drove my car
off the road because I was like so
excited so then I was like telling all
my friends I gotta go out with this guy
like I've been doing I've literally
fantasized about the guys okay Z yeah
and then I started following him on
Instagram and he posts a lot of photos
in bed with his cat and that to me is
such a deal-breaker I literally can't go
back
Wow yeah it's weird not that he has a
cat but he sleeps with the cat laws
eight night hard-on and your cat like
thinks it's a post your hard-on my god
he really hates my dick is the size of a
cat house crazy no it's not it's not
because he loves the cat it's like first
of all cats shed you don't like the
sanitary make your throat scratchy and
they rub on you and they're and and I
don't want any animal in bed with me in
a guy if I'm not your own animal if it
was your animal it'd be one thing but
it's weird to like you feel like you're
intruding on their relationship any
animal that shits in my house Burger
King exactly have you ever been at
someone's house and like you go and they
have a cat and you go in the bathroom
and there's in they have the kitty
litter box and they're not
they're like what is it somebody already
[ __ ] so why am I in here so then you're
just [ __ ] in the litter box by yourself
it's so gross that's the greatest story
ever was George Clooney's story about
like he they had some guy they were this
is like he's to play pranks this is my
favorite George Clooney story ever and
so they did they had this guy who had a
cat and it was a roommate and so what
they did was is they he was like
obsessed with his cat so they did was
every time the cat would [ __ ] they would
take it out of the litter box and the
dog the guy kept thinking this cat was
having problems taking a [ __ ] and then
they went and one day they just went and
[ __ ] in the litter box oh yeah like a
huge human [ __ ] guy thought like his cat
had like a ship had been backed up and
[ __ ] like this huge human like corn and
gum in it that it was like the guy but
the guy like you know was like oh my god
my cat finally went to the bath how
could you
okay I'm gonna go over to Becky's house
and collect all her cat [ __ ] and then I
am gonna eat Taco Bell I am gonna [ __ ]
in her cowboy
it'll be so funny when you did that
speaking of [ __ ] I posted on Craigslist
that I was okay I just did this to be
funny I posted on Craigslist that I was
gonna sell my used panties for $50 I
didn't say who I was I just wrote used
panties fifty dollars in an under
description
I wrote cooped in only oh my god and I
got like 17 messages just go to Ross and
get a bunch of underwear and poop in
them and sell them if that is what
they're into why don't you capitalize
why don't why can only girls do this
because if this what happened Jews would
all have college well this is the thing
I posted it on there I didn't even put a
photo or anything so they're just going
on all they know is panties were
[ __ ] them they don't even know what
I
I'm gonna post my underwear which is big
pictures of you well that's what I was
gonna say then I started thinking any
dude could do that cuz I'm not gonna
[ __ ] in underwear why not you can have
the ones I have on for real I call
triple e I was like if I sent you a
couple pairs of g-string would you [ __ ]
in them for me and said about you he was
like what the [ __ ] and then I explained
why why wouldn't you just do it yourself
like honestly if you're already I can't
I can't plan a [ __ ] out like that oh
yeah you have to plan it out but like
just keep some underwear next to the
bathroom and then when you have to go
you know
hey just wipe your butt with them like
no no here's what you do just don't wipe
and go play around to tennis and then
just sell them by the way I hope that
girls cats okay also if you'd like to
buy my shitty underwear go to my patreon
I'll be selling them there alright we're
almost out of time but before we go I
always like to ask everyone because the
show is called T fails if you have like
a horrible date story like worst sex
worst date something terrible that's
happened well the guy I dated last year
for like two months whatever has best
night of our lives VIP tickets to a
hockey game went and sang live band
karaoke got wasted went out to this
great diner afterwards like eating
drinking having fun laughing literally
like the best night we had had in the
two months and at the end of that I he
looked right in my eyes and said this
isn't gonna work out and broke up with
me that's the diner in public while I
was wasted and I was like wait like
crying like hole ahead and that's how he
broke up with me that's the fool who
told me to take his watch dude let's go
light his car oh I just so don't care
they'll see you now that I actually have
a real man that's I actually had a guy
who dumped me right after sex while we
was going bad oh no it's just we had sex
and then he rolled over and he goes did
you know that right after a guy comes we
have like this moment of clarity where
we just realize kind of like how we feel
huh and I was like what and he's like I
just don't know if I
really want to date someone right oh my
god like literally we're still naked
like he just came and it was like got my
stock back from you just that there's a
wet towel thanks for coming and then he
was like let's go get food wet inside of
a diner and just like stared at each
other's the kiss of death for us
apparently awkwardly yeah yeah totally
and then I was driving him home and then
we stopped to get gas he's like I'll
just walk from here and he just left I
swear to God he walked no unbelievable
stories make me feel so much better I
gotta tell you I don't think I'm good
for you guys yeah there are some bad
guys you are not one of those bad guys
what about you guys have you had a
horrible day horrible something
it was it was like a long time ago but
I'll never forget it was like 11 years
ago I haven't been on a date a long time
but it was that we went to the Laugh
Factory right I was doing a show for
rusty Dooley is another comic who's
raising money for his brother was a good
cause a lot of good comics where they're
Dane Cook came out to help and
everything is a nice event so anyway I
did the show I met this girl after the
show she was very forward right and just
was like about it refreshing no games or
nothing right I had two friends with me
and Jill's knows them they're not comics
Kevin and Jay oh girl that like me had
one friend so it's 2 to 3 so I'm like I
made it clear with them like look this
is she like me I like her you guys had
good luck
you know to the death or whatever to
dorks but whatever as far as I loved
them so then we could like go back to
there this girl's house and you know
we're hanging out around with the one
girl and then Kevin goes in the room
with that girl and then Jason on the
couch like staring at me I'm like what
would he do and take a walk right he did
go to new rule to go anywhere else
he totally cocked box how he was being a
total jerk I think it was I think he was
open if he hung out long enough maybe
like you guys loser double-teamed like
that anyway what he was trying I don't
know he wasn't giving up on the other
situation I think it was just pouting
and I'm like being not so sexy but the
craziest part was so I woke up the next
morning and I hope
with the girl right and I says but in
the morning she says she drops this bomb
she goes I'm getting married in a few
days oh jeez I just wanted to get out of
my system I totally just got used like
that like he's like that's a bad thing
whatsoever there was no it wasn't I
think that was kind of gonna be it
anyway but that reminds me of like when
you were like I'm gonna just have a
one-night stand your friend was gonna
tell you we're doing it this is a
one-night stand tonight yeah I'm on a
mission I felt like she was in your
shoes I said last night on Felipe's
podcast
I only ever have one one-night stand and
it was like a mission because I'd never
have one my girlfriend was like you have
to have a one so I went to saddle ranch
looking a long time ago like five years
ago I was only 48 then that's a
superpower you can go out and just pick
whoever you pretty much yeah
I never do with Doakes it's such a
gamble because I found that
statistically for me only like one in
seven guys is really great in bed so
it's not worth the risk of him being not
that good for sure for sure and you're
just like how often are you really
attracted to somebody that's what I mean
that you have that chemistry and there's
something I don't know so I just don't
even bother anymore or I end up like
getting drunk and throwing up on them
that's nice yeah court you still want to
get together what about you you know I
have I have one one of my favorite
stories ever was I was doing La Jolla
Comedy Store and I think I was with I
think it was it was Freddy Lockhart and
I were doing this love Freddie
and I and after my set I walked outside
and this girl this girl this guy come
out and this girl was kind of drunk and
she came out she's like she was being
really flirty and but there was a guy
with her and she's like you know she
started that all think oh my chamomile I
was my favorite I've seen a hundred
times and I started this whole thing and
I was like oh that's great you know bah
bah bah but she was kind of like like
overly flirty and I was trying to pay
attention to the guy like a but you know
thanks for you know yeah you know and
so then I go I'm gonna go back inside
and watch Freddie you guys should go
back in - he's really funny you should
go back and so I was like so I walked
back in and and then I walked around
behind the bar you know just kind of get
away from me and they walked back in the
show and then a couple minutes later
once I saw them in I walked back outside
I was smoking cigarettes when I still
smoke and I was staying outside smoking
a cigarette then this girl comes back
out and she literally is like I just got
and I just moved into my new apartment I
want you to come see my apartment and
you know she was really for it and I go
what about that dude she goes that's not
my boyfriend she goes we're just friends
but you know that I was like okay so I
go if you really want to hook up I like
it she goes yes yes and I go well my
car's behind the the Comedy Store after
the show just meet me by the car cuz I
don't you know I don't want to walk it I
don't like walk out of here with
somebody you know it's kind of weird I'm
gonna so I said meet me back by my car
and you know we'll go check out your
apartment win Queen right no show me
your edgings yeah literally so after the
show I walk around to the back and there
she's standing there and she's she's
pretty she's kind of drunk so I was like
you know it's kind of debating and then
and then she kind of was sober you know
she kind of sobered up enough and I was
like all right let's [ __ ] go do this
she was hot
so we we go back we she gets in the car
we drive to her apartment and then she
starts playing the you know the panties
on panties off no yes no yes no yes so I
text myself on my phone she goes to the
bathroom i text myself I'm dropping the
dog off at your house you can't you know
you're gonna have to come home tonight
and so I was like I go oh listen I can't
stay
I got a drive back to LA I got to go
pick up my dog my friends dropping them
off the house right you text it to
yourself did it come up on your phone as
like from me yes she didn't know we
showed her the text and so she's like I
showed you the text no you're lying
yeah guys never show you their phone
unless they're lying so I so she's like
okay and then it was like then panties
off [ __ ] you know it was like game on
and then so I took off and it right
after I was like this chicks [ __ ]
batshit crazy
clearly I took off and I'm driving back
and Freddie calls me Freddie's like dude
you'll never
guess what happened I was like what she
goes that was that chicks boyfriend she
left him there and she had the keys she
drove him there she had the keys to the
car so this guy was like standing out
front like knocking on the door like cuz
he had no way home so he was like she
left him all night in the parking lot
but the horrible part is that her
boyfriend didn't know about uber like
what this before uber I think he finally
had to call I think like two hours later
how often she does this to him if this
is like a common ride home
like I like and you know and got home
and showered you know be clearly bleach
bad friend like you were at least
considerate of him like yo is that your
man yeah with him I don't know I didn't
care about him what's crazy is Felipe
told a story like this last night about
an audience member just yeah it's
probably the same one yeah I met Jorge
Perez told a story about how an audience
member took him home and then her her
boyfriend showed up I feel like these
girls are just like they must get to
some point where they're like I don't
even care if my boyfriend shows oh
they're caught we call chuckle [ __ ]
[ __ ] right I'm saying so easy for
them I was on the road with jim
Florentine and some chick walks up to
him after the show was just like take a
walk with me and I was like she's gonna
blow you in the parking lot and he was
like it's obvious that's the only chance
some of us have you know what I mean do
you have to do well and then you have a
window of time good catch I'm usually a
six right now I'm an eight for like the
next three hours we're not gonna talk
about this on stage just on a podcast
names [ __ ] I know everybody on my
Instagram is like how are you single I'm
like have you ever listened to my
podcast I'll be single for I always said
I would never want to date a guy who
like saw me on stage as their first
meeting with me I'm like I would not
want to go out with you if you liked me
after what you saw on stage that's how I
feel I questioned more judge
did I just talk about shoving a
hemorrhoid back up my ass while we're
doing it doggy style you're really sure
you're on board for the ZOA track I know
wow did you really do that
wow that like four days ago I just kind
of threw up in my own mouth yeah Jill
West for the biggest date consider as a
boyfriend you guys were awesome thank
you guys this was an absolute blast one
more time tell them where they can find
you it's me Jill Kimmel at Twitter and
Instagram yeah and the Kevin Hart show
the Kevin Hart show next Friday night me
and Brian both Friday night Comedy
Central 11:00 p.m. what about you Kourt
you can go all my stuff's at court
McGowan cor TMCC o WN and you can catch
me on next season's Arrested Development
that's right oh and he'll be the next
Bachelor ladies yeah what about you we
had a lot of good inventions on this
show by the way we got a new horn for
the car yeah hey yeah we don't shooting
right now I can smell it that's not true
what about your social media rich ericc
ice italiano underscore Brian Whittle
why because my parents have to be
difficult all right I love it guys thank
you so much for listening make sure you
stop by if you happen to be in Phoenix
stop by the all things comedy fest it
goes on to is it till Sunday night
through Sunday their shows Sunday night
also through Sunday night the shows are
freaking amazing
stand-up live and Tempe improv and then
there are sort of other venues around
that these clubs have gotten really big
for the big wigs yeah yeah you're gonna
go pool party lay my fat ass in bed all
right go shop hemorrhoids
guys I love you please check out my
patreon patreon com backslash Kate cute
funny I'm sending out photos to you guys
that sign up this months oh my god I
noticed they're nice oh god stop that
was just for you just show me a few
photos I'm in a hotel room with lots of
hand towels
of course I love you guys see you soon
bye